when working hard your main source of  energy is carbohydrates kept in glycogen  stores the glycogen stores are like  reservoirs of power during hard workouts  the carbohydrates in these reservoirs  are broken down into smaller units of  glucose and transported by the  bloodstream to power your muscles and  your mind but the stores only hold  enough carbohydrate for around 90  minutes of exercise go for longer and  you'll need more carbohydrate otherwise  you'll be out of energy you have to slow  down and you'll probably stop use sis go  range when working out for 90 minutes or  more to maintain carbohydrate supply and  avoid depleting your energy stores try  SAS go range for energy